hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game also from the Hungarian
rapid Championship you guys said that
you would enjoy uh seeing more of
swedler's games and I've checked a lot
of them this is a game from the final
round and he's facing he's not facing
I'm in Tabata by this is actually uh
from the from the previous video sorry
about that uh he's actually facing uh
none other than kirochenko now
representing Romania he has the black
pieces and it's uh it's a really I mean
this game is a bar fight it's an
absolute slack Fest if you I don't know
if you remember that um it was like 20
years ago I was a fight fight between uh
yoshiro takayama and the Don fry and
it's like if you've seen that fight this
is the game that represents that fight
if you haven't do check it out really
just brutal uh but yeah uh that being
said let's check it out Kittle has the
white pieces and he opens with Ponte E4
we have Pawn to E5 Knight to F3 Knight
the C6 and now Bishop to B5 Aikido goes
for the uruil Lopez we have a six by
swedler uh Bishop to A4 and Knight to F6
with castles in Bishop to C5 the
so-called New York angle it's a
variation and it you know produces more
interesting games because here Bishop t7
is the top move then let's say B5 you
could also go Knight captures an E4
Bishop to C5 is just a very very uh
versatile approach to handling this we
have fantasy three castles uh and now uh
Pawn to D4 attacking the the bishop goes
back to A7 all been played before and
now Bishop to G5 and this is now much
much stronger uh for example than if the
bishop was on E7 then Bishop to G5 would
not be as impressive so Ponte H6 Bishop
to H4 and now you know that at some
point if you play G5 uh kiddo will just
play Knight captures and G5 taking those
two pawns for for the price of one night
and getting the attack for a rapid time
format it's as good as you're gonna get
especially against the strong player
like Peter so e counters and D four C
captures and now comes spawn to G5 uh
Peter gives kiddo a deadly there and of
course kiddo does not back down Knight
captures on G5 H captures Bishop
captures and now Bishop capture Sun D4
at least uh okay your opponent gets the
attack but you've eliminated his Center
and now you don't have Ponte E5 if White
had E5 for free then it would be already
game over so Knights the C3 and now Pawn
to B5 and here's where
uh the fun part actually happens there
is a game between Sebastian fella and uh
aerobica Village that was played two
years ago where Bishop the C2 was played
uh but here with Bishop to B3 and both
moves are kinda uh handling the same
problem your Bishop is attacked you have
to move the bishop but the actual
strongest move here is Knight to D5 and
now how are you taking care of this this
is a huge problem for black if you
capture the bishop and you don't really
have anything better than Queen to F3
and now even more uh attack is happening
here if King the G7 then just Queen to
G3 so the best for black here is to
actually give up the queen Knight
captures and the five Bishop characters
and the eighth Knight captures Pawn
captures Knight and then Bishop goes
back to G7 and you will have uh two
Bishops in the knife for a queen uh not
I mean usually a great compensation but
here your King's uh position is a bit
ruined so it would definitely be white
who would be playing for the win here so
that's the way to do it but yeah very
interesting we or the position has
already been reached and whenever it was
reached the either best of the B3 or
Bishop to C2 was played the Knight of D5
being the actual best but okay Bishop to
B3 and now we have Queen to E8 Peter
just unpins here uh we have knighted to
D5 and now Knights to H7 of course a
bitter doesn't want to just trade here
he wants as many pieces defending his
King as possible Knight to H7 attacks
the bishop but now Queen to G4
threatening all sorts of nasty ideas
here uh and uh luckily for Peter there
is a beautiful free move and that is
Pawn to D6 just opening up on Discovery
so white is not in time to
uh threaten any discoveries uh himself
uh Queen to G3 and now we have Queen the
E5 by Fiddler you could even capture the
pawn but it's rapid of course you don't
have time to calculate because you can
easily counter any checks here and even
if Bishop to H6 check picking up the
Rook doesn't really matter you're just
gonna trade Queens let's say captures
captures and now after Bishop captures
King captures an f8 and now Knight
captures on C7 okay attacks the Roku
goes back you go back with the Knight
and you will have two pieces for The
Rook uh definitely uh very much a
playable position uh but okay after
Knight the G3 Queen to E5 he offers a
queen trade he is very happy that he
survives the attack he now wants to
trade Queens but now more problems come
his way Knight the F6 with check and now
what do you play here uh you kinda have
to capture the Knight because if you
don't then Queen to H4 and you will be
in trouble for example King the h8 queen
to H4 and again the queen uh you'll have
to give up the queen in order to stop
Checkmate so here Knight captures an F6
right away but now another disc recovery
Bishop to F4 check followed by capturing
the queen so King the h8 and KIRO wins
Peter's Queen we have Knight captures on
E5 and now Rook 8 to D1 so okay white is
definitely a little bit better here but
uh the bishop pair is looking very nice
the knights are very strong and if you
can get those Rooks into the game for
example double up on the semi-openg file
could be a very hard to defend the white
king So Bishop to B6 and now King to H1
we have rooked the G8 attacking the
queen and queen to H for check King to
G7 of course Peter wants to hide his
King in the center of the board and then
mobilize the Rooks on the king side
Queen to G5 with check we have Knight
the G6 you can't move back because then
the Knight hangs on Knight to G6 and
here
uh you have to continue with something
uh not as potent as what was played in
the game so lucky Bishop to C2 or Rook
dt1 but in the game F4 was played and
now Peter is completely winning but you
have to uh figure out why this is so so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute move for Peter uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
beautiful uh Queen trap and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight captures on e4 uh looks like
you shouldn't be able to play this
because uh well what if Queen to D5 just
attacks the Knight and threatens Queen
captures on F7 this would be even worse
because now Knight the G3 check only one
move H captures and G3 and rook h8 and
that's it the bishop covers G1 there is
no defense here you have to give up the
queen and that is it Rook captures an H5
with Checkmate so after Knight captures
on e4 uh we have Queen to H5 and now
Knights the G3 with check this is how he
wins the queen back H captors and Rook
to h8 now nicely connects with the queen
and the Rook so like I said an absolute
uh bar fight here uh Queen captures you
have to give up the queen uh now King
captures and The Rook to D5 so okay now
uh Peter is definitely back in the
driving seat but he still has to win the
game King to G7 we have Bishop to D1 and
now of the E6 chases away The Rook Rook
to H5 and now Bishop to C4 uh attacking
The Rook you could even capture the pawn
here but he doesn't bother with that
Rook def 3 and now rookie 8 he wants to
get his Rook over to E1 King H2 and now
Rook to E1 attacks the bishop here with
Pawn to B3 now offers to trade Bishops
and uh well Peter could play this many
different ways he could go for some
ninja moves with like Bishop G1 checking
H3 then Bishop to E6 with the check and
this would absolutely destroy white but
he goes for the calm Rook captures on D1
because this is also very much winning
for him Big B captures with B captures
and pawn to G4 now now white is out of
options white now has the advanced pawns
hope to hope to you know make something
happen and Thriller will simply Queen
his C pawn and that's exactly what he
prepares Bishop D4 he covers the C3
Square Pawn to F5 but now even Pawn to
C3 he doesn't care about the Knight
because the pawn is Unstoppable the
bishop covers the C3 Square so Pawn to
G5 now KIRO will try to Checkmate here
uh sweller's King we have C2 and Ponte
F6 with check King to G8 and now look at
this beautiful move Rook the B3 the idea
behind Rook to B3 is that if silver
brings the queen into the game
uh then he just loses Rook the B8 with
check look at this Knight to a f8 rook
captures an fa with check King
characters only move and Rook to h8 will
be Checkmate as the pawn on F6 covers E7
and the G7 so of course uh Peter did not
fall for that after Rook to B3 he played
Rook to B1 and he was in this position
on the Move 40 that kirochenko resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh you can't trade because he
just gets a queen there is no Checkmate
there's no Contra play if you do nothing
then just C1 Queen and that's pretty
much it there's no no good way to play
this
uh so yeah uh very nicely done by by
Peter swindler we've seen the previous
game from a penultimatron Against Time
in tabatabai and this is the game from
the final round against kiroshenko and
you've seen I mean it was just a very
very uh dominating performance uh like I
said if you haven't seen that uh that uh
fight that I mentioned in the beginning
of the video uh do find it online and uh
check it out it really does a remind of
this game you know just trading punches
uh in the end Peter comes out uh on top
uh so yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed it and thank you all for trying
out our new app for uh trying to improve
at chess um yeah if you guys still
haven't checked it out do try it it will
be the first link in the description
below and for those of you who have
tried it we would very much appreciate
it if you would rate US on both Google
Play and on the App Store uh so you know
give us your honest opinion and uh well
give us a rating it will also help
others on the App Store uh find it and
maybe also uh try it a little bit uh so
yeah that's the game really you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank bullet
just thriller.com
and Rod Hill for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day